what's up everyone welcome to GameSpot
if you're watching this you're here
because you have either beaten uncharted
for a thief's end or you just
desperately want it spoiled for you one
of which is here with us Pete Brown has
not beaten the game but he's comfortable
that's spoiling it he's gonna lend a
different perspective than tie rob and I
who have all finished it correct it's
Korean yes yeah so there's a lot to talk
about story heavy game in a lot of
different ways and it tells a story
pretty well in my opinion I like the
game a lot but Pete but I figured it'd
be a good way to start off and tell us
where you are in the game yeah and where
you think it might be going it oh we
might just jump into and spoil it
okay so chapter 11 in Madagascar
yeah it's about halfway through chapter
wise yeah yeah and I played everything
up until that point in one sitting
because I really liked the game and I
had never really beaten any of the other
games in the series so this was sort of
like a new start for me and I really
enjoyed it and I wanted to go back but
I'm moving I've been really busy I had a
lot of fun playing it and I like this
story that they present but I'm not like
emotionally invested in it so I'm I
don't feel like I'm gonna be missing out
too much because I know I still have a
bunch of great game to play okay so I'm
I'm in cool let's do it sweet so you
just got the Madagascar I think correct
right like just got the Madagascar yeah
like they they gave me control of the
Jeep and I turn off the system yeah so
you go like a lot of people don't even
want us to spoil it like outside of this
they don't wants to spoil the location
so I met its Madagascar after Scotland
after you know like Boston as a kid New
Orleans when he's living with Elena
but then you go to liberate alia you
find out that Henry Avery the legendary
pirate captain who pulled off the
biggest heist in pirate history on the
guns way his ship has four hundred
million gold and the brothers Nathan and
Sam been chasing it for a while like
their whole life and they finally track
it down like where it's gonna be liver
tally the clues Liam there you find out
later on the Rafe and Nadine kind of
corner Drake and Sam on this like cliff
edge in Bluebird Talia and find out that
he's you know you got Hector Alcazar
hanging over like looming over the whole
time you kind of assumed he might be the
final villain it turns out he was he's
been dead a few years when Sam came but
Drake it was actually he Rafe came back
to the prison found like he had searched
Scotland couldn't find anything he came
back because he knew Sam might have like
answers for him so he just bribed that
guards
walked out of the prison right oh yeah I
remember that what was that no you don't
know that was yeah nope I thought I
remember him walking under the prison
cuz the guard was like oh I want to let
you in on this thing
no that was Nathan that was Nathan no
Sam you find out later that Sam came out
and made up the whole Hector Alcazar
thing B ticket because he knew Nathan
might not be on board I think he had
like assumed because when you find out
when they were kids they made like this
pact like they were basically you're
rummaging through their mother's
belongings and they were in this like
big mansion I forgot whose mansion that
was whose their moms like archaeological
partnerpartner' okay yeah so you find
out why they took the name Drake they
weren't like what was their actual like
Morgan Morgan okay yeah and and then you
find out that they're say hey you know
Nathan Drake it was rumored he had no
heirs but maybe he did have heirs who
the hell knows and so they just take on
his nation for ancestry yes yeah just
Drake and then they make a pact right
there to go find Avery's treasure
because that was what their mom was
working on and that was what they wanted
to like kind of like do as as a brother
tandem to kind of bond like this is what
this is our purpose right and that from
that point forward you're like okay this
is where the direction they're headed
and it and I think what was so amazing
to me was Sam is a new character we've
never seen before ever and we had no
idea Nathan Drake even had a brother
until this game so my biggest concern
going in there's how are they gonna make
you care about who this person is how
they gonna make you relate to Sam how
are they going to actually make you care
about Sam or fear Sam or question him
because you know we're used to seeing
Elena and Sully and Nathan you know and
and and what maybe Chloe whoever right
like these are like classic iconic
Uncharted characters I thought they did
an awesome job considering that you
don't really it's really just the Sam
and Nathan show for most of that game
you know so Li obviously shows up so is
Elena but they really make you kind of
care and relate to Sam a lot you're like
you you're invested in him you know like
it in fact midway through the game when
I said it when you know the title is a
thief's end I thought it was gonna be
his end I thought his greediness and
desire to find a B's treasure and put
that above all else was gonna meet his
ultimate demise at some point you know
it just seemed like a very cliche kind
of you know archetype to follow in that
case you know but they really make you
care about him and I thought they did a
great job with that
and they really that and it really hits
home for for me and you know I'm sure
you guys as well when they you know
after the big the big bomb with you know
Sam's lie you think
well [ __ ] Sam but then right after he
takes he takes a bullet for his brother
yeah like it's that constant back and
forth dynamic with those two guys where
you just you care about anything you
don't then and then that's why I also
felt like initially when my biggest
beefs was like it when Sam drops the lot
the lie like the whole thing was a setup
just to get his brother out there Nate
later on you know you you see Nate isn't
initially really upset about it I
thought later on you kind of just
forgets about it and you know he in the
he's just like I mean I need to save my
brother then he's Dennis from then on
out it's all pure I love you brother
I'll do anything for you yeah there was
a moment where I was like I needed a
little more disagreement I needed more
anger out of Nate for basically [ __ ]
up his whole life when he was quite
visibly pissed off when he found out his
brother yeah but you lied to him you
know yeah I guess my concern I guess
maybe why I didn't feel the same way was
because my biggest fear when that
double-cross happens I don't even want
to call it double-cross it was more like
Sam Liz lying because he wanted to
convince his brother to get out there
and help him find this treasure he knew
the only way to do that was to lie and
say my life's in danger
because Nathan would definitely risk his
life to save his brothers and that's the
only way they can have this brother
experience right this bond this pact
they made with it and that was
understandable from Sam's way yeah yeah
exactly and I think that's why Nathan
took him up and say okay yeah we have to
rescue you have to save you you know but
my biggest fear was like I didn't want
it to be like that very common archetype
you see like in these brother duo movies
were like you know you think they're
friends and everything's great the
entire movie and then the very end it
turns out he's just a double-crossing
[ __ ] who like betrays his brother you
know so it wasn't the sense of betrayal
as in like he's like hahaha
I've been working with Rafe and is it
Nadine Nadine Nadine Nadine all this
time but he still liked you you felt
work he felt remorse he did feel guilty
you know and he was really worried about
his brother finding out and you could
tell like he was not happy when when Ray
just you know let the cat out of the bag
and said hey by the way your brother
lied to you ha ha ha you could I just
could sense his remorse I'm like man he
must feel like [ __ ] you know dang well
he also I mean like he for a while he
wasn't working with Rafe he kind of
double-cross Rafe he didn't like went
off on his own to get because he did it
for his brother he said this is what me
and my brother were supposed to do we
made this pact as children or as kids
and so he took Rafe up on his offer but
eventually double-crossed Rafe to say no
[ __ ] you I'm gonna go do this with my
brother because this is what we were
meant to do so yes he lied to Nathan but
I think maybe why there wasn't a lot of
anger there was because maybe maybe
Nathan was like hey I understand this is
what this is was meant for you and me to
do together I totally know the scene now
that makes more sense yes the scene that
you and Jake were mentioning which is
when the reason why I think Nathan
forgives Sam is because when they find
out about Avery poisoning all those
people and there's a moment where he is
getting so riled up and the camera stays
on Elena
yeah and he's getting so riled up and he
says I'm sorry yeah because that is the
moment where he realizes you know what
yeah my brother double-crossed me and
all this stuff
but I needed this I had a normal I
switched to a normal life I have a deep
passion for doing what I'm doing and I
could blame Sam for screwing my life up
but in reality this was something that I
needed and I actually wanted deep down
inside but what was that job that Elena
was trying to convince Nathan to to
Malaysia Malaysia which was illegal they
didn't have the permits to dive for that
with the company so that was both of
them like that was Elena's way of saying
like we are not cut out for this normal
middle-class you know white picket fence
like yeah right so what I don't get is
why Nathan felt that he had to lie was
it because she was encouraging him to do
that job in the first place because that
was the lesser of two evils I think in
saying like I'm going to Malaysia I'm
actually gonna take it without you like
I'm gonna take it but he just didn't
want to do that because it was illegal
and he was fine he was done with that so
let me ask you this one because I don't
know does there come a point where I
mean obviously Elena finds out that
Drake with Nathan was lying to her does
she ever say to him like why didn't you
tell me oh yeah so that's close to that
scene actually where you are okay they
get back to your man she's like all come
they get back in and that shows this the
cameras like inside the hotel room is
looking at the door and him and them
walk in after they found out so yeah
there's more of the pirate story that we
can get into it they go ahead they get
back and Drake looks behind the camera
oh [ __ ] and I thought the room was
ransacked yeah but it was just her like
looking at this stuff she was she had
she figured it out like there's a phone
call earlier where you can tell by the
way about the look on her face and the
way she's probiem she knows he's lying
yeah she knows the [ __ ] she's like
how was the how was the storm there I
heard it's dangerous he's like yeah
delay the job a couple days and then you
could tell like she like hesitates and
then she knows lets him like I know
about the storm was there not even a
storm that's what I thought like oh
maybe there was a like that's what I was
thinking and she just didn't want to
call him out there because she was that
like shocked but what's interesting
what's interesting is it you know she's
yeah she goes I think she moves to the
computer like I'm I'll buy tickets right
now she's probably like I'm buying
tickets so this is what I felt this is
what I connected with the story so much
because and and I don't know if this is
cuz I'm older or because you know I
understand what complacency is like but
that's why that opening the whole
opening chapter you know where he's like
diving for you know south or south he
works for a salvage company in New
Orleans he's just trying to use it it's
a good regular honest job right and you
can just tell he's bored
he's complacent you know going starting
the way the game starts we are in his
attic and he's basically going through
all of his like accomplishments all the
treasures he's found all the adventures
he's been on you know and he you can
tell he he kind of escapes up there
right - kind of that's his life prior to
this like very domesticated experience
with him and Elena and then you know
it's come like also the tutorial so it
kind of is like hey this is to remind
you about all the adventures you've been
on and here's a nerf gun to remind you
what fun it was to be like in combat and
crap you know coping and and the funny
thing is is like it goes back to like
him and Elena on the couch you know
they're playing Crash Bandicoot it's
kind of fun but at the same time you can
tell like both of them like that they're
just bored and they're in a rut right
they're trying to figure out what their
purpose is they're not cut out for this
kind of life and think about it that
whole thing never would have happened
had Sam not come back and lied to his
brother you know he would never would
have been able to convince Nathan to
come on an adventure with him if he just
said hey I'm out of prison
let's go find this treasure absolutely
in his mind he's like wait no I promised
Elena I would leave this dangerous crap
behind right we would start our normal
life everything's else but the same time
and there's very end of it and you'll
you know when you are you gonna beat it
just whatever fine doesn't matter point
is we're late on them for everybody
anyway at the end of the game like both
Elena and Nathan come to this
realization that they needed this this
saved their marriage this saved their
relationship or and themselves they but
their needs they both are like two they
don't like being complacent but it was
them coming to grips the fact that you
can do that in a legal setting that's
not endangering your life exactly so the
epilogue which I'll talk about if you
don't mind no no you go back to playing
it cuts like when you think the game
might be over it cuts to you play Crash
Bandicoot again I'm like are you serious
is the credits and you beat it and you
still can't beat the high score which is
still 3,500 which is what Elena set how
many probably like 12 years before this
and it pans around it's Cassie this
blonde like maybe 12 13 year old I'd say
yeah next to the dog in this like really
it looks like a tropical setting but it
was it was the Gulf of Mexico it was
probably Louisiana or somewhere again or
no I I'm for media that is not or maybe
like nothing golf amiss no I made like
maybe like it was like blue water as a
Caribbean man okay gradient so you and
then you like you go you're looking for
Nathan and Elena who are mom and dad and
then you go into this like this office
this Hut next to it and you see look on
the walls it's a DNF like our DNF
excavations it's this company that they
clearly formed on the cover like
National Geographic there under cover of
time so you find out that they found a
way to be adventurous and reconcile like
their own nature in a way that's not
endangering them or you know in the
future with Cassie and you start and
then of course she like finds this
cabinet that's locked and she finds the
keys finally and then Drake and Elena
are off doing whatever and they're you
you've seen notes on the fridge saying
they're getting ready and like Sully's
gonna come visit a few days with Uncle
Sam and stuff and she unlocked his
cabinet finds all like the skull she
finds the piece of the Chintamani stone
she finds you know the the Dublin that
set off the first game fact that he went
to Shambhala and yeah all that kind of
stuff and so then Nate comes in they
kind of find out that she's doing that
so like oh [ __ ] now we have to tell her
because they found the picture that was
taken the first game of Elena Sully and
Nathan on the pile of gold from the
other one so she's like what the [ __ ]
cuz dad like dad's got a shotgun over
shoulder what is that and then so they
start asking her and then like it just
becomes like Nathan
the way they're silent Ripert start
telling her the story like oh it started
like back in like whatever like they're
like where to start and then that's why
it kind of frames the first three games
of cool way you could play four and then
go back but also it just like it kind of
drove home the fact that you know like
they talked about st. Dismas the whole
time right the penitent thief he was the
one like supposedly in the Bible he was
crucified on the cross next to Jesus he
was the penitent he did that payoff I
felt like they were hidden that nails so
no so that was the whole thing this is
like you're worrying because you start
to find out that Henry Avery was in fact
like recruiting the best pirates to pool
their treasure and create liberabit alia
this through these really elaborate
initiation schemes yeah fine like that
was [ __ ] that was just there that was
just their effort to make like a
treasure hunt that's also the series
right just the idea of it to me it was
just like no I did it's cool because
you're more like relationships in the
modern day fall apart you realize like
what the treasure did to these people
and you're like [ __ ] this is happening
to Drake and up until like the last boss
fight so you find the treasure and
you're in the guns way like that was I
loved it I thought it was amazing like
he's also it's cool because he's chasing
Sam who's chasing the treasure she like
so you're like [ __ ] I think Drake might
still be obsessing the treasure too and
the way that they show the treasurer
like without much fanfare you walk in
the ship and in gameplay is just oh
there's the treasure and you start
walking over it to find Sam he doesn't
give it like a [ __ ] about the treasure
and 400 million worth of gold
he literally you fight the last boss on
it Rafe don't get in the sword fight
which I really liked was one of the best
boss boss fights I've ever played yeah
this was a actual like duel where you're
you know like you know I won't go too
far into it but it was a very engaging
boss fight that like you know I lost but
many times despoil okay let's get into
it man and Sam Sam nearby is pinned
under a wooden beam they can't lift them
right yeah you show up he's already
there yeah he's under it but anyways
yeah you finish it well now you're
fighting Rafe and like rapes the only
ones still Nadine just like alright [ __ ]
it's not worth that she leaves with like
the few mercenary she has left that
sucks
she was like a really cool care yeah she
was she was she like pretty much told
Rafe told Rafe like screw off and she
was she played her part like I thought
what she did was
believable she was like okay [ __ ] all
y'all you're all crazy
I'm taking what treasure I can find and
my crew and getting hell outta here
she had the like the smallest steak and
everything she was doing it to save the
company pretty much yeah she knew Rafe
was on to like the whole I have a real
quick question when I backtrack a little
bit
so at the the auction right where Sam is
dressed as a waiter and Rafe and Nadine
her standing there yes you guys were
telling me earlier and I'm kind of thing
about it again now that they had some
sort of working relationship no at that
point they didn't they did they didn't
see Sam he was like that's I was think
about that specific he's like in maybe
they didn't see him but he's like feet
away yeah but I think he like he
realized like they had to turn the
lights off anyway like and then be right
near the thing so I guess that was just
because Sully was distracting or
whatever because the way it worked out
is what Rafe originally hired Sam he got
him out of prison to help him find this
treasure and then Sam double-crossed him
and ditched him and that's when he goes
and tries to get Nadine to help him yeah
yeah and also you kind of Sam looks
really nervous that entire time and that
makes more sense
but like you're like oh they're about to
pull off the heist but he's done that
stuff before
oh and even in the first steps of the
villa he's like I'm gonna go outside
here you guys go downstairs and then so
it makes sense he's he doesn't want to
Rea 42c want to be anywhere near any of
that yeah and also really cool thing
about the Prison Break that you play is
him that like never happened and you
play it it's like the way it's all live
so a true detective kind of did like
their narrator and trust me but they
actually made you play it yeah which is
cool it's almost like they're investing
you more in it and then the game like
also kind of betrays you in that way and
that's really cool because actually when
I saw Jake Decker playing through it
that same chapter there's these little
parts of dialogue in the game where
people are saying like this is going way
better than we thought it would and the
whole time you're thinking like this is
going like really well every time you go
to your door to bring to explode those
people conveniently got by the guard
somehow really quietly this is all too
good to be true and it turns out it was
and that's it's really cool when you go
back and look at it how like I thought I
was reading too much into that but then
like watching him play when hearing that
dialogue saying people saying like yeah
this plan is working out way too well
and soon yeah and I even remember like
as that game progressed like halfway
halfway through you're like where is
that ultimate villain that they hinted
at in the beginning like I on the inside
Rob yeah exactly
what's greed I mean the whole thing is
based off like greed and like putting
that ahead of your fam
right I mean that's like the whole
that's a whole like synopsis and theme
of this entire like game is the sense of
like okay you know when do you let go
and just say okay obviously I need to
reevaluate my desires the things that I
really want what's most important to me
you know like you and like Mike
mentioned when Nathan finds the treasure
when they find you know when I Willy
ship in the middle of that freakin
mountain you know like it's like it's
like there's the treasure it's there but
I'm looking for my brother I came here
to get him let's get out of here alive
and let's prioritize what's most
important right now of course the funny
thing goes at the very end when you know
Nathan and anna-lena when ain't no
laying the counter like realize that
they can have if they can have this
adventurous life but do it right and do
it less dangerously and they kind of
reconnect and everything's great and
they reconcile that's when you kind of
see Sam and Sully go off and be like
well you know I have 15 years to catch
like to catch up on in terms of like
getting out of prison and wanting to
kind of be adventurous and and still
live that life and Sully clearly still
does too
and so they kind of go off and just do
their own thing and you know and that's
when Elena drops the bombshell I go you
know I bought the company
I bought the salvage company and we're
gonna go get the weight of treasure with
actually it turns out Sam did sneak out
a few like a bunch of golden coins of
course yeah and that's how it was and
that's how they were able to buy the
business and go now and then she's gonna
film like a documentary about the
treasure because she gets to do what she
wants to do and what she's been dying to
to and then dying to do and then Nathan
gets to go and get the treasure you know
and it's all legal and that's just yeah
and that's the whole thing with a
penitent thief like he was brought into
paradise supposedly and here's my
crackpot theory that I had kind of come
up with that whole thing the ending is
like like almost too good it makes sense
it fits because like I came to grips
that he realized like he's done with a
[ __ ] that's why it's called a thief's
end yeah what if like what if just
throwing it out there kind of like stir
the pot I love it what if he really did
die and that like that last epilogue is
just like the Paradise because it's
[ __ ] it's paradise like this tropical
setting he's got everything he's got
what would have caused him to die cuz
I'm not privy to what it could have been
like the ship sinking like yeah it's not
like a concrete thing but it could have
been the ship when he was on it was
burning down and the only way he got Sam
out from under the beam was to like
purposely flood the room yeah like ramen
so the last shot is you know the
entrance to where the ship came into the
cave is crumbling down and they dipped
to white yeah yeah I know so that's so
that could be the only way but then
again I mean I don't know for this to
pick up right away I think your theory
would stand better if it went
immediately to the epilogue sure right
then it would be more like oh did he die
don't actually believe it yeah I think
the good ending fits I think I think
after the stuff there like there's a lot
of things we don't the time touch on
that Drake did come to like that one
scene you find the bodies of like 10 of
the 12 pirates on the this table and
that's where Drake is like going I was
like these are some of the greatest
players that ever lived
yeah and it does this like shot on the
lane Oh while he's talking doesn't show
him and you're saying like and she's got
this look on her face she's like hey I
think she realizes like she he's not
gonna change they need to do something
but also they needs like this dangerous
lifestyle and also be she likes it too
whether she not and she's it's not like
she's just being pulled along like she
is there on her own accord yeah it's
like she calls the shots at the end of
the game pretty much which I liked I
think they're you know like I think
earlier in the game she feels kind of
like this ancillary character that
they're using conveniently but later on
she really comes back and like alright
I'm taking over this what we're gonna do
we're gonna have this kind of this
lifestyle we want but we're not gonna
like endanger ourselves and that's why I
think I told you both like at the very
beginning of that game I got I got kind
of teary eyed you know because I was
watching this experience between Elena
and Nate in the very beginning where
they both it's like they're not being
100% honest with themselves so therefore
they're not being 100% honest with each
other
like they're like you can tell like they
have like some sort of an intimacy issue
they have very small talk type
conversations it's like how was your day
at work great how was your day at work
know you told me about your day you know
and it's like very kind of just small
talk right
it's very surface level stuff you know
and I feel like any long relationship
will go through this rut where like you
might run out of things to talk about
you may not be doing the things that you
love you're so worried about the other
person and their happiness do you kind
of put your own needs aside and I
thought they did such an amazing job of
like of just making the player realize
what they were going
and I think that's why like it spoke to
me so well because it's like so many
times have I been in the situation where
you know whether it's with an
ex-girlfriend or some friends we're like
you just feel like something's off and
you feel like something's not quite
right that you're putting someone else's
needs ahead of your own and you kind of
forget what was important to you you
know and instead of actually having a
conversation about it which is what
would be the healthy thing to do and
just open and have an intimate talk
about it
you kind of just play it off like it's
just surface level enough Dubai is a
different problem yeah that you think is
you know something towed yep distract
you exactly five distractions you know
and that's why it's like you know here's
you know whatever play Crash Bandicoot
here's our typical day I'm just gonna go
rescue this stuff I'm not gonna do the
Malaysia job which we don't have the
papers for it even though Elena's
pushing them to do it you know it's like
all this stuff or I guess it was
actually his boss that was pushing him
to do it even though the illegal one
yeah yeah then when she got the permit
it was yeah it was fine but it's just
one those interesting things that I
that's why I felt the story was so
strong and such and just grounded almost
in reality to a point you know I mean I
know that like it's easy to check your
mind at the door because there's a lot
of crazy [ __ ] that happens in these
games and we haven't even gotten into
like some of the set pieces that
involved in this game that are
unbelievable but like the story really
does push you all the way through and I
didn't want to stop playing it ever the
way the world reflects what's going on
you know the more like you learn about
the fight the Pirates thing falling
apart it's not even about the Treasury
more it's about the obsession yes and
then the more there you start to realize
how messed up things got you see these
barricades around let me tell you're
like oh [ __ ] went down the relationships
with Nate and Sam and Elena and slowly
start to fall apart and then you that's
when like Drake in that scene with the
Pirates realizes he's like [ __ ] this
really screwed over all the Pirates uh
Henry and two before you find out that
to die to is like Henry and to both like
just wanted the treasure themselves he's
like I'm going down that same road he
identifies with Avery who identified
with st. Dismas the difference being
Avery didn't come to grips with it the
Drake did speaking of the world
affecting around them something that I
thought was so awesome and someone
really took the time to develop this is
when you first get to the island you see
this the mountain peak and if you Verity
have you seen it yet this there's like
it's like the Grinch or like a hook
mountain that's basically in it is where
the ship is okay you don't think much of
it it's a really cool
looking down as you kind of mosey around
the bay and when Sam drops that lie you
have that back
background know that sorry the flashback
oh yeah oh yeah and then you basically
when you come back out of it you look at
the map that same mountain you've now
reached the other side of it mmm and it
looks like straight up a shark head that
there's certain peaks of it when the
light and teeth and teeth and now
there's an eye on it basically it's what
you were led to believe with your
brother coming to the island thinking
this is a you know elaborate amazing
adventure and then when the lie unfolds
you see the true nature of the island
then the treasure and then Avery start
basically having their own second
meaning yeah what well plus the game
itself gets more difficult right around
then you start having more firefights or
at least like needing to use more
stealth and there's more enemies and
they kind of like the world itself and
you start that's when you really start
to see you find all the mansions of the
individual pirates and you see them all
like just destroyed between each other
this inner this infighting that happened
detail but who is the skeleton in the
cage and the title screen no no there's
a ton of there's a couple areas that
have that and I was trying to look for
it there's a bunch of guys I couldn't
find the one with the house also you go
into this escape shaft out of Henry
Avery's mansion when you start to
realize how crazy and how obsessed you
become and you go in this one room and
it's like the what was it the the mouths
of the people who lied to me there's a
skeleton jaws and some strings then it's
like the ears the people or the the ribs
of the people that like the heart who
took my heart or something like
something like that or just kinda
pleases yeah like crazy yeah and then it
gets even worse when you get down like
and they have like those like mummies
that are booby trapped
yeah just gets clearly paranoid crazy
yeah and that's that's like the thing
about Liberty alia why it's cool how its
set up it starts to parallel this
stories and it shows how Drake kind of
his character arc resolved itself
because you do a second flashback when
they're kids it's the same exact the
first flashback ends when you get on the
motorcycle to go find the mom's notes
the second one picks up where they left
off you find her note about Francis
Drake and about Henry Morgan and you
this old the older lady who owns the
mansion like points a gun to you and
almost calls it she does call the cops
run from the cops actually pretty scary
part there are pretty tense part but you
find out that she was friends with
Cassandra Morgan their mom and their dad
was just like shitty dad left I was like
when she died it was like I was like oh
that's unfortunate
yeah that way he died too because she
like basically is she's so old and she's
like smoking and old and then like she's
like don't worry I'll take care of the
police I call them I call them on you
cuz I thought you were bad guys but I'll
take care of it
yeah and then they just you have the
ball from the police and then you pick
off and then he's like I'm not going
back to the orphanage and he goes his
brother to do stuff yeah
steal and they just become and they are
now so and then him and Elena there's a
part where you're like kind of you're
worried they're not gonna like reconcile
it and then she starts to kind of like
four oh and also her joke with me so I
was who's gonna die who's gonna like
really make this like cave in because
these characters are so amazing and
there's a fall at the end of that escape
short explosion where Elena and Nate at
the ground and he he gets up and right
away you know I never talked about Elena
isn't moving she's got she's laying down
with her back he's in the foreground
that was some crazy
the joke is their relationship like that
is what they were missing right they
were missing that bond the excitement of
just screwing with each other and then
she was like what we're even now even
yeah or no I think he said we're even
now I could be butchering this I think
he's never even out she's like no we're
getting there's just like that's one
problem solved I was like you I was like
I was like there's no but that's the
thing at no point did I ever think they
were killing anybody off in this game
like it's pretty important I knew that I
just I sat there and I was like it's
kind of an easy way of the edge to
create like you know it's it's one of
those things a cop it's a cop out right
well I'd even I don't call it a cop out
but like it's one of those things where
you know in this day and age where were
kind of now been groomed to be used to
just really important people dying
thanks to george RR martin
you know I just thought that like it's
too easy right to just kill somebody for
dramatic effect you know like just kill
someone off the only thing again I was
really concerned about was I was a
little worried about the whole like you
know I have to save my brother
you know archetype you know whatever
like it's like the whole gone in 60
seconds cliche where it's like my
brother did business with a bad guy and
I have to like go save him now you know
but they cleared that was all why it
wasn't even real you know and it just
found out that his brother just wanted
to find this treasure with his younger
brother you know and that was all that
he really cared about so I thought they
resolved it well and they didn't use
anything for just dramatic effect it
wasn't like we're gonna kill someone off
because that's what you're supposed to
do right like in these kind of games
that's kinda what everyone's expecting
you know and so in a way I thought they
threw a curveball by not killing anybody
important off I know it's a very happy
ending I get that you know but at the
same time you know I just felt they did
a good job of just maybe keeping us on
our toes and wonder if it was gonna
happen because I always I actually
thought Sam was gonna die at the end I
thought like when that beam was on him
yeah he's like yourself but then I
thought wait Nathan's not gonna leave
his brother back again yeah he had the
guilt from the prison yeah I think we're
I why I really felt like someone was
gonna die was cuz I remember how I felt
after last of us were like that won't
have that finished that game okay much
but basically like you know throughout
the journey that happens mmm throughout
the journey of it right and every time
you're like oh man like who who's next
like that's how I felt about that game
but then you realize that this is yes
still Naughty Dog but they were able to
pull those strings together right yeah
and fix and combined such a brilliant
story from Last of Us and the
action-adventure
the light-hearted tone of the Uncharted
series and it was just like I didn't
know what to expect cause I thought they
were so similar it was just like I said
it was just a really solid story like
for a video game especially in anything
like I don't even know why they would
want to make a movie like now it doesn't
make I mean that is the movie like that
is that could be a perfect you know
scene for scene take by take version of
a freaking film because it just follows
that three-act structure so well plus I
mean that's why I was explaining to you
why I played with auto aim or lock-on I
did you because it doesn't seem to be
that's testing your skill more than it
is taking you along for God and so yeah
like I'd I was treating it as a a
film-like experience for the most part
but I got to you know play a part in
from here you know from here and there
but well it's like what did you find it
just different I see I didn't play like
that at all did you guys find it
difficult no I turned on to begin with I
turn off from the start I mean the thing
is okay
my biggest like the game fits it it just
seems like my biggest issue with games
like this like my only complaint with
the loss of us were to me again the best
parts about that game were when I wasn't
playing it is this when I was watching
the story unfold now that's me
not everybody is like that I get it you
know but in this particular game I
sometimes in previous in charges felt
that sometimes the gameplay
especially when I played on hard could
almost kind of get in a way of the story
and I'm really plain and charger for the
story I don't think the gameplay in
uncharted is like revolutionary and
amazing it's not bad but it's not like
life-changing you know it's not it's not
know you're solid it's not you know it's
it's it's just it's very serviceable
gameplay that helps you prolong you know
and extend the narrative right and I
just figured okay listen I'm not playing
this game to challenge myself really I'm
not playing this game
to like get humongous headshots or kill
shots
I just want auto aim on so I can kill
these guys move on and move forward and
by the way we didn't talk about this but
you kill so fewer people in this game
than previous Uncharted spiteful
specially if you want your trying yeah
but back to your point though like about
just killing guys like you know all the
time magically like you look at some of
the scenes like especially like the
orphanage scene where you have these
teenagers jumping like 15 foot gaps yes
like they're doing this inhuman stuff
like all their superhuman [ __ ] all the
time to me it made sense that they could
also be sharpshooters yeah you mean like
an expert was like a Deadeye with his
gun - yeah and so I just like for me it
felt like at least for the way I wanted
to experience the game
lock-on was a good way to do that yeah
oh cool I mean I didn't even think I
mean the game without that I find out
really interesting that everyone kind of
seemed to like not you but like other
people I think Mary was doing the same
thing it's it's very that's why I like
when I go back and replay it again I
might use just for fun the bullet time
you unlock any time you raise your gun
it goes into bullet time limited and
that's the thing the game itself is just
in its pacing in its momentum it just
continues even it's like quiet moments
and it's
fast-paced like I'm getting dragged
through a river in the mud climbing up a
rope jumping from a truck and yeah no I
that's this game it just maintains
momentum throughout everything in like a
lot of different ways and that's why I
love it so much
and that's what I was gonna say like the
the pacing of it I think is just
top-notch where you have like these
brakes right even brakes you don't even
have to take like there's that scene in
liver Italia where like you could walk
up to a table and chairs and and you
know pop up a chair and sit there and
have a conversation with Sam you don't
actually have to have that conversation
but oh yeah you just pick up up you have
you just you you just had a crazy moment
you just start talking about life and
about his story and Nathan's story and
they they're kind of reconnecting more
and more you know and it's cool to have
like those little conversational moments
where like you don't have to just dive
into action scene after action scene you
know or and this remind me a lot of the
Last of Us where after Ellie had that
crazy where she killed I forget who was
it Henry
she crazy the nolan north and then you
know he's the crazy guy i'm sure getting
like this survivors group in Colorado
and it's no one north Lee comes anyways
Troy Baker and then right after it's
like this giraffe scene where like it's
like called a huge shot it's the exact
opposite as far as like an emotional
roller coaster you just go through and
she's enjoying this moment and you are
too and that I remember choking up that
I think there was a very similar I'm
gonna try to get it as Naughty Dog is so
freaking good at stuff like that
we're like after Nate loses so Lee and
Elena and he's still with Sam and they
go out the next scene is you want a boat
in the tropics and it's amazing and
you're clicking beers but something else
isn't clicking which is Sam like hey let
me get you a beer like hazing isn't this
the light he's over selling it yeah sure
it's not doing it yeah he's just like
sorry nathan is just like yeah man and
then and then throughout the rest of
like the next 15 minutes is like really
kind of passive-aggressive dialogue
between the two as you pull out of the
mat so yeah as you're playing the game
like like uh-huh like where'd you go
like my buddy he gets lost for a second
he's like where the hell were you and
they're like yeah and even when they sat
down for that
conversation you could tell Sam still
doesn't know whether nathan is coming
back to him he just like he kind of like
looks he's like wild Nathan's talking
he's kind of looking at him like his
whole like he's voice to kind of shaking
yeah guilt is coming out or doing
something you know they're not coming
forward
try harder do I just it goes both ways
right like you're not yourself right
that's what Sam's like what do i do how
do I handle this we get some beers you
know it's so well done so I want to
close this out real quickly we've been
doing this like 40 minutes so I want to
close this out what you guys think about
the prologue or the epilogue sorry at
the end where we find out they have a
daughter who also is you know because of
her parents also a very good treasure
hunter what do we think with how this
franchise will be treated into the
future do you think we'll get a nether
uncharted with with Cassie do you think
we'll get in there uncharted maybe with
Sam and Sully's adventures what do you
guys thoughts I think they'll continue
it with Cassie if anything they've said
like the one thing they've confirmed is
that they are done with Nathan Drake yes
oh really not just Uncharted or no
Naughty Dog's said they're going with
Uncharted right but but Sony owns but I
would but yeah I would not be surprised
to see more on charters from someone
else with Cassie probably Santa Monica
something some other like first party
studio yes a mica studio yeah first I
wouldn't be surprised at all yeah and I
don't I wish they I'm glad like Nathan
Drake had his character arc and it's
done yes because there's no one else
taking Nathan Drake nobodies they'd
better not because this is it's his end
it's tough where does the mobile game
fit into his arc I didn't play that it
looks Nathan Drake's character model
looks ridiculous yeah whatever it's like
that whatever yeah I would go sorry go
ahead
raaah Naughty Dog will reign supreme on
that series like no one will be able to
top that I feel bad for studio like that
has to top it right like I don't know I
don't care I'd rather just see something
else from NIDA well I mean I think you
will I also think that this kind of
gives them a chance to take what like
five years off six years off me totally
maybe when the playstation you know six
comes out or whatever you know whatever
the new console was then in like four or
five six seven years like they revisit
this with Cassie and kind of reboot the
series but with a new character because
it's like at this point what do you have
you know you have you haven't charter
which seemed like it just ended its
entire series and now we have tumor 8 er
which you know I don't see that stopping
anytime soon I'm sure they'll make
another one after rise of the Tomb
Raider so it'd be interesting to see
where they go from here but I would
agree I would like to see maybe
something with Cassie in like five years
it's just a way of you know keeping that
open-ended but yeah really nicely right
like you could go either way you know
like a there wasn't like a firm Cassie
will be appearing in the nice I think
they tied up everything they needed to
yeah or anything they could have I'm
sure they're like Chloe you see a note
from her early on the game yeah she's
the only one that like and he said he'd
reason I got another lifetime Chloe or
something also by the way I'd like to
maybe end it finally like I just thought
it was really cool to see no dog thank
Amy Hennig at the very end of the a
definitely um I thought that was
fantastic because she's been such a huge
part in those first three games
especially so that was really cool to
see Naughty Dog kind of give props to
her yeah her work on the franchise
definitely that was like what right
after the credits ended right there's
the full screen herself and yeah very
cool anyway so that's the end of our
spoiler cast if we miss anything that we
didn't get the time to talk about feel
free to start a conversation in the
comments tweet at us whatever but yeah
if you haven't finished the game like
Pete I highly encourage you to go finish
the game now it's still worth very much
worth playing through just to see how
they tackle all this stuff and how fun
it is you guys havin to not diminish my
interest in finishing this oh cool cool
right awesome well anyway until next
time see you guys
you
you